I'm your new quartermaster but you must
be joking well has it I can do more
damage on my laptop sitting in my
pajamas Ben you can do in a year in the
field so what do you need me
maybe now and then a trigger has to be
pulled or not pulled tartan a witch in
your pyjamas double-oh-seven
because it's the 50th anniversary the
pressure was on to make the best Bond
film ever
that is the first Bond movie ever an
IMAX I was incredibly excited by because
it elevates the whole experience and I
love that it always starts with these
ordinary characters and then everything
that comes along the action the gadget
the girls I have faith in the audience
that they will listen if the characters
a grippy double-oh-seven reporting for
duty finding the right people for the
roles that was crucial made all the
difference we've been blessed
we got great actors ray Fiennes and
Javier Bardem Judi Dench and Miami and
berenice Sam gave us license to create
rich new characters and really
interesting characters they've got to
have history they could have wait the
girls Miami and berenice two
exceptionally beautiful and intelligent
actresses know what's required of them
and they bring so much mr. bond James
Bond
I just forgot totally about the Bongo
seeing because it's a concept it's it's
very abstract it's important for any
character in any movie just to bring
life and substance and create a real
human being
Javier Bardem plays one of the most
interesting villains we've created he's
charismatic but repellant at the same
time it's extraordinary I mean I've
always felt happy is just one of the
great actors working in film today he
had fun and I think he's done something
wonderful
every bomb melanism in the middle ground
of reality and fiction so you have to be
grounded but at the same time you have
room to fly and do something theatrical
a chemistry between Javier and Daniel is
so exciting because you just don't know
where the relationships gonna go the
action always works best when you're
really rooting for the characters and be
really rooting for Daniel who
give us an unbelievably extraordinary
performance I'm really excited that it's
it's gone romance release and looking
forward to creeping in the back and
watching it